[Music]
hey you guys
talking about another movie this is one
that
uh one of our patrons liam sent to us
yeah this is a great movie
this is actually one that i even though
i love tom hardy
and i love british crime movies i had
actually never heard of this one this
came out in 2015 and it's called
legend yeah this is kind of like
the british equivalent of goodfellas
yeah it does have a lot of similarities
with yeah it's a period piece
taking place in england this is all
london in it yeah
pretty much london and uh in the 60s
so it's got that's like a period piece
and they do stuff in it
that you could only do in the 60s which
is [ __ ] great for especially for a
gangster
movie it's about these two crazy [ __ ]
british gangsters
and their relationship with the mob and
what the american italian mob and then
what ended up happening to them later on
it's [ __ ] wild man it's wild it's
wild movie pretty good
yeah this isn't actually this is the
first uh isn't the first movie that i've
seen that was about the craze they made
one like back in the [ __ ]
god damn was it in the 90s there was one
just called the craze
which had um god what like the kemp
twins
gary and martin i think are their names
uh and they were in it
and that might not be the only one i
feel like there was more than that like
made about the crew because they're
like [ __ ] super super famous like in
the uk
yeah i have no idea how authentic this
movie is historically
it doesn't really matter i mean
you just want to watch a good movie that
was the same with goodfellas i don't
care how
accurate that was or not some people say
oh no it's an exaggeration
doesn't matter you're telling a story
yeah and the thing about it is even if a
movie is based on a true story
it's still a movie yeah so it's not
actually what happened you're not you
weren't there filming the [ __ ] yeah you
know what i mean it's not a documentary
every time every time i see tom hardy in
a movie
i gain more respect for him as an actor
i like him um
[ __ ] he was great in in uh fury road
a lot of people [ __ ]
dinged fury wrote a man oh man that's
just too feminist
whatever man [ __ ] that was a [ __ ]
great movie all right i like fury
actually
fury road was a mixture of everything
we've seen it like 10 times
he was great in bronson which is another
true crime movie based on some real [ __ ]
he was [ __ ] great in bronson he was
good he was great in batman he was you
know i
i like you know i like him he's a cool
ass dude yeah
and it seemed like he what what i heard
was that he was so excited to do this
movie
that he wanted to play both roles
because he plays both twins
and he said i tell you what um if i if
you let me play
uh one of the twins then i'll play the
other role for free because like i said
you know honestly you would get paid for
two roles obviously because you're doing
two roles
um but he wanted to do them both so
badly and it's just
it's really good because much like in
um you know some other movies where you
have the same actor playing twins and
i'm thinking like you know uh
you know like dead ringers you know like
jeremy irons playing the twins
you can tell just from the body language
and the facial expressions before they
even say anything
um you know which twin that that it is
yeah you know what i'm saying yeah it's
funny because ronnie and reggie
yeah yeah [ __ ] reggie was the
the sane one yeah ronnie was [ __ ]
crazy he was i mean
they declared his ass insane yeah
schizophrenia well they only
let him out because reggie threatens the
psychiatrist
yeah they you know they threaten the
psychiatrist yeah what's weird is
reggie's straight and ronnie's gay yeah
but you know
he says what do you say he says i'm a
masculine gay right
no he didn't i don't think what did he
say in the movie he's well he was the
funny thing about a guy
he said i'm a guy i'm into boys yes
he told the mobs that yeah and they were
like
and this was like yeah or maybe late 50s
actually
that [ __ ] did not fly with the italian
[ __ ] mob yeah but they were
they kind of were like they were taken
aback for a second and they were like
all right
whatever he said you did take it took
balls for you to just say that out loud
and then but you then you know the guy i
don't know that actor's name but he's
been in a bunch of italian gangster
movies that's chaz paul material
it says his name yeah yeah after he said
all that that he's taking he's looking
at looking at him like this
motherfucker's crazy
he was crazy though oh he caught him
right yeah he's [ __ ] crazy well like
i said he got diagnosed with paranoid
schizophrenia
you know rather early in his life and
the only reason that he was let out
was because of reg um
you know basically threatening the
psychiatrist and like you know threaten
to kill their families or whatever it
was he did
like to get his brother let out and
honestly after they both got caught like
reg went to prison
uh but they sent ronnie back to uh
broadmoor
yeah because he was paranoid
schizophrenic yeah and it's like it's
pretty pretty clear
in this movie he did he did say he was a
masculine
gay though remember that when when they
meet when he was living in that trailer
and the dude came out yeah dress dressed
a little bit well he just said
he just said to francis he said uh oh
i'm a homosexual he said to her
and she was just like oh i'm a giver i'm
not taker
or something [ __ ] like that you know
what i mean he tried to make sure that
he he was trying to let it let everybody
know that he was a top he wasn't a
bottom
[ __ ] funny but uh he was a badass
though he's [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] shoot you in the face right
[ __ ] public and everything
i mean honestly one of the best scenes
in this was when they go
to that pub to like meet the emissaries
from
the other the rival gang the torture
gang and it's a set
up um and reg knows that even though
they're kind of pretending they're gonna
go to talk about a truce or whatever
and he goes there and he's just like
real calm drinking the beer and then he
says i gotta you know something like i
got a joke for you he's like a paranoid
schizophrenic walks into a bar
and then [ __ ] and then ronnie comes
back in with a [ __ ] hammer and starts
beating the [ __ ] out of all the other
yes oh god it's like it's horrifying but
it's also like hilarious we need to do
an episode on reggie and ronnie cray
i'm you know what i'm amazed we haven't
done one yet because they're fascinating
fascinating characters i mean obviously
they're pieces of [ __ ] they killed a lot
of people
um yeah it was gangsters though but it
was gangsters yeah um
you know what i mean it's not the same
situation it's not they're not hurt
they're not
going on civilians these dudes are
willingly in this business kill each
other over money
it's like joining private armies you
know i mean it's not the same as going
out and [ __ ] killing and murdering
innocent working people you know
that's a big difference you know what i
mean it's still illegal
you can't wage war on another group when
you're inside
inside the jurisdiction of a country you
know you can't do it
but they were they were doing it and
they were hanging out with the [ __ ]
wealthy elites and all the
politicians of being well that's how
they got away with a lot of stuff
because they had
dirt on a lot of them that's what i did
like about the movies it had the balls
to point that out
that the ultra rich and the ruling class
and the criminal class
are have a lot in common a lot of yeah
they even say that they say that
outright in the movie it's always been
that way
they're making money off of scams making
a lot of easy money
and they have no predilections towards
any of these middle class moralities
they're [ __ ] they like their [ __ ]
blow and their hoes and
and they they're naughty all ruling
classes
like that going back to the [ __ ]
roman period they're like that because
they're not the same rules don't apply
to them when they get in trouble they
can get out of trouble
when you got money you know money well
yeah dirt on everybody
that's i think that kind of went a long
way toward um
you know how powerful they were not only
because they were [ __ ] ruthless and
if you just got in their way they would
just [ __ ] kill you especially ron
because he was like a lunatic
he didn't have any [ __ ] yeah he
didn't really have any compunction like
he
he legit walked into a crowded pub
and shot the head of the rival gang in
the head
in front of everybody yeah with all
those witnesses
which actually ended up getting them
caught like well actually reg ended up
like flipping out
after that and like murdering another
dude like at a party and also in front
of a whole bunch of people which also
ended up getting
because at that point everyone was like
turned on him yeah the thing is though
is that if
i always compare people to the italian
mob so you you
italians you can go ahead and take a bow
you go
the italian mob in its heyday all right
it's not quite the same
type of deal it's not the same situation
as today things have changed but the
italian mob in its heyday
had organized crime down to a science
and they started on street level for
guys that came from the street
they ended up [ __ ] doing doing super
super well
and over time most of those families
went straight because they owned so many
businesses they didn't have to commit
crimes
they were doing this [ __ ] to get into
the middle class in the upper class
that's why they were
were gangsters they did you know they
didn't necessarily do it just for the
shits and giggles
they were mission oriented so it was
goal-directed violence
and why i'm telling you this is because
reggie would have made it in a scene
like that but not ronnie
not wrong he was too much of a loser
right [ __ ] um
the ice man who was a good italian yeah
kuklinski he worked for its italian
late italian mob as an assassin klinsky
would have killed reg instantly
ronnie iran excuse me reg he would he
would
well he would have killed him they kind
of go into this in the movie and this is
actually it's kind of based on a
biography i don't know if i'd call it a
biopic it sort of is
um but the focus of it is on different
things the focus of it
is honestly between you know on the
relationship between the two brothers
and also on the love story the
relationship between reg and his wife
francis so so you have and that it's
almost kind of like a love triangle and
a little bit it's not
not exactly the way i'm pictured like
saying it but there was a book called
the profession of violence the rise and
fall of the cray twins that this
draws largely from and i think
there are times in the movie and you
were saying this while we were watching
it
where you're like in you know red should
have absolutely
killed ron or like taking him out of the
picture at some point
but the fact that he couldn't do that
because he was still he was his twin
brother and he still loved him even
though
he was essentially like ruining his
business because what ended up happening
at one point and they showed this in the
movie
he was reading everyone's business yeah
he was ruining everything i mean he was
just because like i said he was a loose
cannon they didn't know what he was
going to do he was doing all kind of
crazy [ __ ] he wasn't like really careful
and what ended up happening was that reg
he
kind of sort of wanted to sort of go
straight like when him and francis first
got together because he wanted to be
like a good man for her whatever but i
think that the allure of crime was too
strong for him
but he did own some nightclubs which
were like legitimate businesses
and he got put in prison for some just
like [ __ ] charge it was like six
months or something like some
outstanding warrant
and while he was gone ron was running
the nightclub and in six months he ran
it into the [ __ ] ground
yeah like no one was would come and
everyone suffered
yeah like everyone that worked there and
[ __ ] like that and then all the other
gangsters that depended on that place
running well for an income
they all suffered and you see when
gangsters don't have good income then
they have to go out on their own and go
commit crimes
so having a lunatic in charge actually
is worse
much worse than having a sane organized
gangster involved because he's keeping
all these other gangsters in
under control well because everyone's
trying to make their own trying to make
money
this is the thing a lot of people don't
realize the reason why mafias exist is
because they're
conducting businesses that prevent them
from access to the legal system
so if somebody steals from them they
have to handle that they can't go to
cops
all right a mafia hitman is kind of like
the executioner and the police force or
the cops
of the mafia if one of these gangsters
gets out of line
bringing on too much heat towards
everyone else everyone's at risk
if he's a made man in other words the
guy that's bringing on the heat if he's
made
they have to have a sit between the
bosses and and then they say yeah
let's kill this guy then they send a hit
man to go and get him all right
they usually come at him with a smile
they have no idea that
the hit's been placed on them it's
murder
or an execution all right if they're
nice to you and you know the there's no
hard feelings it's a bullet to the back
of the head
it's instant you don't even know that
they did it if you're not a maid man
they don't need to sit like you're just
a junior level
guy who joined up you know what i mean
that you're not made you know
uh you're you're like a mercenary they
can kill you for just
bringing any heat they don't need to sit
there just go
get rid of him he's you're a junior
member you know he's bringing heat
you know he's doing this and that he's
out of control we're all going to get in
trouble
kill him yeah you know well ronnie
ronnie would have been hit in in a
well-functioning italian style mob
ronnie would have been hit in a matter
of weeks
well and he like i said him uh you know
doing what he was doing did actually end
up getting them all
well actually led to you know the their
fixer
guy whose name was payne who's played by
david thulis in this by the way
um he actually ended up flipping on them
just for that very reason because he
because that guy was was legit he was
like a barrister or whatever
or whatever and um well they even there
that one scene where reg
the same one where he just stabbed the
[ __ ] out of uh jack the hat i think like
at that party at the end like in front
of all those people
he did that and then he just goes up to
to ron and said you know i did that
because i can't kill you
yeah he wanted to but he couldn't
because it was family
see the problem is [ __ ] bags
psychopathic violent criminals are a
dime a dozen organized crime doesn't
need them what they're looking for is
good honest reliable criminals those are
hard to find
and that's really what the mob was about
they were trying to get the best wants
but you need these execution you need
these hits to happen
to weed them out you know to get rid of
dudes their heads get too big
walking around trying to be famous i'm a
gangster oh you get hit for that too
all right they told the italian
mafia told reggie that they're like the
problem is that you're famous
we we don't allow famous we
we like anonymous you know what i mean
they didn't
they wanted to work with him but they
were worried that about him because he
was famous
yeah everybody knew yeah a famous
gangster through the craze where
everybody that didn't happen in the
united states after the 20s and the 30s
the capone era that was the end of the
famous gangsters
yeah they were all [ __ ] stealth
which like i said you know it's better
if you're doing a bunch of illegal [ __ ]
you don't want to be like hey i'm this
famous gangster look at me
yeah yeah your life span is very short
yeah either like the cops are going to
get you or a rival gang's going to
[ __ ] bump you off or something like
that which like i said it ends up
happening in this one because
i guess um the craze their kind of
territory was on one side of the thames
i'm assuming
like they were more east end and then
you had this other gang the torture gang
and so they were always kind of like
beefing with one another so there was
that whole thing going on
and also there was a cop uh who and this
is played by the
uh fantastic christopher eccleston i
love him uh
he was uh he played nipper reed and so
he was the guy that was like following
them around and like trying to find dirt
on him because everybody knew they were
gangsters that's when
they were famous they were famous in the
east end even before they got famous
like
countrywide you know what i mean because
they
they did it's funny because i feel like
where they grew up
like their mom loved them even though
she knew they were gangsters everybody
knew they were gangsters but everyone
thought they were cool guys or at least
they thought reg was cool
they kind of had a robin hood
personality too they did yeah and they
um they were charismatic
yeah all gangsters were charismatic if
you weren't charismatic you couldn't be
a gangster
true he just couldn't even the italians
were like that the italians
um you know in their heyday
they could go to the governor's house
and eat with the governor
and the governor would felt safe to have
you around the kids you know chief of
police they were all on take
yeah they were all in the take they had
a a good relationship
outside the law with each other on a
personal basis you can't have a bunch of
psychopathic [ __ ] [ __ ] like
you know reggie craig or ronnie craig
right you couldn't have ronnie craze
around
there had to be quality control yeah
because he was a crazy person he's
[ __ ] crazy all right
i mean you know and he brought down
their whole little empire
pretty much had had he been hit early on
[ __ ] reggie would have lasted a lot
longer probably yeah
yeah which you know like i said and so
so this
the movie like i said it does go into
like a lot of the crime and stuff that
they did obviously
but it's sort of it's weird because it's
narrated
by uh francis who was married to
uh reggie gray for a while and she is
spoiler alert uh she actually did kill
herself as she just as she did in real
life
and um i think that i think they
slightly changed it into the movie i
think in the movie um
you know she left him because she was
basically like
she wanted him to go legit and he said
that he would
um and then he kind of went back on that
promise
and so there was kind of a big blow up
he got really mad at her and he's like
started smacking her around
uh at which point she left and went and
stayed with her brother
and um you know then he came back and he
tried to be all like contrite and
everything and she said yeah
you know we'll try it again or whatever
but then she committed suicide
i think that she actually committed
suicide when he was in prison in real
life
um not entirely sure but so the fact
that he
kind of did that that's kind of shitty
but he did actually seem to have
loved her and it does seem that he sort
of it
kind of tried to go straight a little
bit but i just don't think it was ever
going to happen
and she was being played by this
itty-bitty british chick
with a supernatural draw line she kept
talking about it like through the whole
baby
he kept shooting her in profile with
[ __ ] lighting underneath to [ __ ]
bounce off the bottom of her jaw and i
was going jenny that can't be natural
it had to be in a store-bought job
she's skinny little bitty head little
bitty head with a big old hair on top of
it yeah because it was sexy
she looks like a yeah it's a cute
haircut and you should get a wig like
that that'd be cute
yeah we were talking about that she
looked like a little bitty lollipop
[Laughter]
she looked like that she looked like
that gothic cartoon character we used to
have back in the 90s what was the name
glenn cookie oh yeah
yeah but yeah so so a lot of the movie
is kind of
um because it's from her point of view
even though it's weird because she
narrates it but
i mean there's a lot of stuff in there
that she couldn't have known about
because she wasn't there
but they just i i guess it's just for
expedient's sake we will say
like i didn't have too much trouble but
i watched some other reviews of this and
apparently like
quite a lot of people said they had to
turn these subtitles on no we did
because
well i usually i usually do that anyway
because i'm deaf but um
you know because i'm deaf as [ __ ] i
can't understand what those [ __ ] were
saying but yeah like as soon as the
movie started well because they're very
it's
very very cockney yeah um so
if you don't know so it's not just you
know them talking really fast and having
that really thick cockney accent but
it's also
using a lot of slang that maybe
americans don't
uh know what that is you know what i
mean people say that sometimes you can't
understand a [ __ ] real strong
southern drawl that ain't [ __ ] man
compared to that
that cockney there man that's like to
mush mouth [ __ ] just
enunciate [ __ ]
[Laughter]
we might draw some draw some [ __ ] out
and slow it down and stretch it and or
maybe make up some weird [ __ ] slangs
in the south
but we enunciate although i will say
that i don't have as much trouble
uh you know figuring out cockney accents
as i do scottish accents although it
depends
who's talking well because like i said
my hearing is kind of bad anyway so
even like with when americans are
talking i usually put the
you know put the closed captioning on
just so i don't miss anything
because i feel like i'm like that old
guy in that [ __ ]
commercial for the for the hearing aids
back in the 90s like
i can't hear you people mumble i'm like
i'm like that guy so funny when i first
met her this is [ __ ] years back might
have been 11 years ago
she was married at the time to a guy
from wales yeah we were in the club and
i started talking to him and i had to
pretend
that i understood him i couldn't
understand a [ __ ] word of what that
dude said
and his accent was not really that big
compared to yelling and it was kind of
loud and then he was yelling and that
and trying to make himself understood in
that accent
and it just sounded just like some
guttural medieval [ __ ]
i was like whatever man okay
i don't know what you're saying man to
me like his accent everything and
especially after i moved over there
um you know his accent was like not
nearly as thick as his family he's
thinking klingon but
you know what's interesting it's like if
you guys um saw my
uh flickers of fear of my review that i
did of saint maude and the interesting
thing about that
is that the the girl that plays maude in
that is welsh
and she speaks welsh in that movie and
actually there's a scene where she talks
to the devil
um and the devil is speaking welsh it's
actually her but it's um you know
they slowed her voice way down to make
it sound like devilish
and listening to it in that context even
though i'm pretty familiar with
you know i learned like a little bit of
welsh you know before i went
while i lived there and stuff so it's
it's not like a completely
alien language to me but listening to it
spoken in that context i can see how
people would think that it sounded like
an alien language yeah it is a very
weird sounding language
and um you know if you're not familiar
with
gaelic or anything like that which is
sort of similar but it's
uh the thing that threw me off the most
about it was that
a lot a lot of their uh vowels and
consonants are not are not pronounced
remotely the same as they are in english
so like they have a lot of the same
letters but they're pronounced
completely differently
and so that threw me off a lot when i
was like trying to learn it
because i'm like what do you mean w is a
vowel that's the craziest thing i ever
heard
but it is um but yeah so there was that
whole thing so
so i will say that if you're not real
good at picking up on
uh british of like real real thick like
cockney accents then you might want to
put the closed captioning on
pretty much 90 of the other reviews of
this that i saw they said they had to
put the closed captioning on
because they couldn't understand what
tom hardy was saying um
and i think it was more it wasn't as
much when he played reg
when he was playing ron he had this kind
of
weird like he he was a lot more
mush-mouthed um because i think that's
what ron really
talked like you know he seemed like he
did a lot of uh research into
what they looked like and what they
sounded like you know to try to get it
right
so i had more trouble understanding ron
than i did reg
um but i don't know it's i'm just saying
that's like a pro tip
but yeah it's it's good because i really
really like
british crime movies like i said and so
i'm amazed
because this came out in 2015 and i
didn't hear about it
um i had never heard of it and then liam
sent it to us
and i was like what it's like it's got
tom hardy in it and it's about the cray
twins
how the [ __ ] did i not know about this
movie i feel like it didn't get
fantastic reviews like the reviews were
kind of mixed a lot of people said
well a lot of people kind of said oh
it's just like the british goodfellas
like it's already been done or whatever
but
um pretty much but all the reviews like
really really praised like tom harkins
yeah and like i said the the focus i
liked it because the focus
was you know it was on the gangster [ __ ]
and it was on the characters
but i liked that the focus was more
about the relationship between the two
brothers and the relationship between
reg and francis that was kind of like
the the focus of the movie and then
there was kind of gangster [ __ ] going on
yeah it didn't really say what
it didn't really hardly discuss at all
what they were doing in terms of crime
yeah it kind of skipped over like it
yeah i'm assuming it was drugs and
prostitution and
maybe running numbers or something yeah
it was like yeah it was
gambling [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] like that right
um you know
they they were doing i don't even know
if they were involved in prostitution
now that i'm thinking about it
um yeah that's that's the kind of thing
i think it was mostly
gambling kind of even though you know
what i mean like a gambling is a lot of
gambling is legal over there this is
not legal over here you know what it was
so i'm not really sure like they were
making enough to buy multiple homes
and cars and nightclubs and nightclubs
and they had some legit
like front businesses but like you said
before i was i was watching
i can't remember what his name is now
but i was watching i found this channel
and it was a guy that used to be in the
mafia
like an italian-american guy and he's
not in the mafia anymore he's like older
now
and he has a youtube channel where he
reviews
movies about the mob yeah isn't that
neat and it's
so i watched he had a review about this
and he loved it he thought it was great
and he actually um you know he had never
met the craze but he knew people that
had met the craze because like i said
the italian mafia went over there at one
point
um and he said oh and i went to london
once and i stayed
in this room that you know that the cr
that reg stayed in like one time or
something like that except it was a jail
cell then because i guess like the
the jail that he stayed in or whatever
it's like a hotel now or something
and uh but yeah he was talking about
that but yeah he loved that movie and he
was like talking about a bunch of the
scenes
like i said i think my one of my
favorite scenes is that one in the bar
where
you know where he tells them the
beginning of that joke like a paranoid
schizophrenic walks into a bar and then
ron comes in and like [ __ ]
hammers the [ __ ] out of everybody that's
like pretty hilarious and um
but you know it's not so it's not a
super violent but it has like
it's it's mostly like character driven
but then it has these kind of like
really super violent like outburst like
that part where reg
stabs jack the hat at the end at that
party that's like pretty [ __ ] brutal
like at the end yeah and there's like
one scene um
with the torture gang who is like their
rival gang where they have a guy like
hanging upside down at a warehouse
they're like electrocuting his nipples
or something like that
well they were doing all kinds of stuff
they were doing all kinds of [ __ ] to him
well they were
uh they had him on trial yeah yeah the
dude had a wig and everything yeah
i had a guy that got the court
chief justice yeah had him on trial
where
he had to call him your honor and
everything oh my god
yeah yeah it's like you know but uh yeah
it's definitely a good movie if you
haven't seen it and you know if you're
into british crime flicks i can't
believe i
never saw this movie uh it's on it's
like we got he sent us the blu-ray i
think it's also on
amazon prime although you might have to
pay right i think it's 299 or
300 or something like that it's no big
3.99 no big deal yeah
so uh yeah i definitely uh would
recommend it
tom hardy was [ __ ] great in it and
it's just like a really entertaining
like i said it's not like a super
in-depth biopic or anything but it's
like
if you liked goodfellas it's kind of
like a british version of that
liam sent us the the blu-ray if i tried
to play it but it's region b
yeah we couldn't play it so we just so
we just watched it on amazon prime
because i wanted to watch it so bad and
i was just kind of like it might play on
the on the other uh you might play on
that one blu-ray player i'm not really
sure but it wouldn't play on the xbox
uh but yeah so thanks liam for sending
us that that was a movie that i hadn't
heard of and i really really enjoyed it
quite a bit
so i guess that'll do it for this one
you have anything else you would like to
add
all right so we'll see you guys on the
next one bye
you